[Music]
special projects Nicole this is Henry
topple how are you settling in Nicole
good sir
the datasets are amazing good good and
everyone is being nice to you yes very
nice give me their names I will deal
with them personally now I have a
question about these 33 rlz submitted 33
RLS I'm sorry which one is that again
winters deep skin summary of private
electronic communications classified
trans and 0-0 200k right email yes these
emails you analyzed how did you have
time to read all these emails there are
millions of them are you a witch the
computer doesn't oh right of course
line 10 read email line 20 go to ten end
of line I get it it's it's a little more
complicated than that we scanned out of
her patterns and key phrases using
algorithm I understand like Jeff or Jax
equation key what is that it was
developed by DARPA in the 1950s we used
to communicate with the hostages in
Tehran
it's a stochastic matrix of fluttering
dice and closing them discrete plastic
cube are you talking about boggles yeah
I am oh we I didn't know we were using
boggle for
kill the Ayatollah computers are more
powerful than boggle when I started this
agency we didn't bother with computers
we had disguises you know when it comes
to gathering intelligence a fake
mustache is worth a hundred computers I
never thought about it that way I once
used a mustache called The Undertaker's
broom to infiltrate Noriega spouse now
that was a thing of beauty probably one
of the top ten fake mustaches ever
deployed in defense of our nation I miss
it what happened to it oh well Missy
I'll tell you in the 1990s our mustache
budget was slashed in favor of these
computers that you love so much why
don't you just grow your own mustache
cuz that wouldn't be a disguise also I
can't grow a mustache I can't produce
testosterone haven't been able to since
I accidentally leaked a bunch of forever
stamps two years ago you know the post
office does of them don't you good night
I didn't you know why they're called
forever stamps
because you can use them forever I that
was gonna be my first guest
[Music]